so hi
welcome everyone um it's my distinct
pleasure to introduce eric white
who i've known since graduate school at
cornell and who many of you know is one
of the most distinguished scholars of
thai buddhism and southeast asian
buddhism generally
in working in north america right now
eric is an independent scholar who has
previously taught at antioch university
cornell university and the university of
michigan
his research explores the cultural
politics of popular religion in thailand
the subculture and religious careers of
bangkok professional spirit mediums
and the social cultural dynamics
underlying claims to authority and
charisma in theravada buddhism
he's the author of numerous book
chapters and journal articles including
contemporary buddhism and magic the
cultural politics of the supernatural in
terravata buddhist thailand rethinking
vernacular religion across mainland
southeast asia rethinking
anthropological models of spirit
possession and theravada buddhism
and fraudulent and dangerous popular
religiosity in the public sphere moral
campaigns to prohibit reform and
demystify thai spirit mediums
he's currently in the process of
drafting a book manuscript
entitled spirit possessions as buddhist
vocation
reimagining piety in modern thailand
i think some of what he'll be talking
about will be engaging with the topics
of that book
so please join me in welcoming eric
white for today's talk spirit possession
in buddhist southeast asia eric
okay thank you eric for that
introduction thank you uh thanks to the
council for inviting me to give a talk
and for chris managing the details and
for everyone
showing up digitally from wherever you
are
in the world and time zone
um
i will share
my screen
so
um
my talk today
uh
is actually about a book
uh it's not the my book in progress it's
uh an edited volume that just recently
came out
uh spirit possession in buddhist
southeast asia world's ever more
enchanted i contributed
the afterward to it um
and
um you know basically i do think it's an
important book groundbreaking and i'll
just say a few things about
initially why um
scholars have been working on spirit
possession in buddhist southeast asia
for
a long time but this is the first book
that has actually brought
scholars together who've been studying
across different regions and countries
uh in mainland southeast asia and
putting their observation and arguments
into conversation with each other
um you know it brings together scholars
who have worked across the different
theravada majority countries in
southeast asia
that's unusual it's also included in the
mix
of scholarship work on spirit possession
in vietnam that's even more unusual
spirit possession and work on spirit
possession in vietnam has tended to be
siloed
in many ways um
and um
the book also brings together multiple
generations of scholars so the editors
benedict and peter
you know they began working and writing
about spirit possession in the 1980s and
irene stangs and i
began working and writing on the topic
in the 1990s but the remaining eight uh
scholars in the book who contributed the
book you know began working in either
the 2000s or the 2010s so there really
is a kind of cross-generational
uh cohort sort of conversation going on
in the book and that's unusual um you
know basically as you can see from the
table of contents there's there's like
10 case studies
and then
uh
five
in
set up uh
five arrange coming out of work in
thailand two out of work in myanmar two
out of work in cambodia won from vietnam
um it's too bad there's not more from
vietnam but there's sort of size
limitations um and then there's an
introduction and then afterwards
and both the introduction the afterwards
a sense you know take it take the
measure of the different contributions
and place them in terms of the
the existing scholarship and then point
towards pass forward
um
and so
i'm going to be
you know my talk today is about the book
and its importance and and the
contribution it makes to the ongoing
conversation um but there's some caveats
it's not my talk isn't simply a
recapitulation of the afterword um and
it's not a detailed or exhausted
discussion of the book's content and its
particular chapters it's i'm trying to i
want to sketch a broader in general
terms the intellectual value of the book
and to make sense of it um and its
contributions i want to place the book
in a larger and longer intellectual
history of the study of spirit
possession in buddhist southeast asia
and see the book as
contributing to an ongoing conversation
and debate that's happened across
scholarly generations and as you'll see
i place the the work in this volume in
sort of what i call what i turn the
third generation of scholarship on the
topic
um
and basically i'm going to be talking
about you know the way empirical foci of
studies the analytics themes and the
theoretical conceptions have shifted
across those generations and
um in a kind of cumulative evolving way
um but i'm not suggesting that later
generations simply
replace the prior generations
uh
you know topics and themes and analyses
but sort of layered and supplemented um
and sometimes with you know agreement
and disagreement
um
the other qualification is i'm leaving
out for the most part detailed
bibliographic and citational references
um
uh i've mapped these scholarly
generational cohorts in these sort of
20-year
uh
groupings which is obviously kind of
artificial and i paint with a
necessarily broad brush so there are
obvious exceptions to some of the claims
i'm making um when i talk about spirit
possession in buddhist southeast asia
i'm talking about the mainland so i
exclude you know buddhism in insular
southeast asia and i also exclude
discussions about the geographic
borderlands
of mainland buddhist southeast asia like
northern malaysia southern china
bangladesh
even india um
and the other thing is i'm not talking
about spirit possession
in upland societies and cultures i'm
talking about it in lowland societies
and cultures it's a it's a whole
different sort the conversation and
debates are a whole different
beast in in terms of the uplands um
and there's likely a thai centric bias
to the kind of intellectual history i'm
going to give
and it's mostly my discussion is mostly
probably rooted in
english language scholarship
so
you know
unlike my afterward i'm actually going
to talk a little bit about the
pre-history of the study of spirit
possession in buddhist southeast asia
which is to say there's this first
generation that i see is starting in
around you know from 1965 but
but
the way spirit possession and buddhism
is thought about before this time period
is important for understanding what
happens later it kind of haunts and even
shapes the kinds of conversations
there's sort of foundational ideas that
are sort of laid down in dilemmas
and they continue to reverberate and
that's you'll see that's part of the
discussion uh
that i uh i'm presenting to you um and
i've given i've tried to give little
tropes descriptive tropes for each of
these sort of
generations
and in the case of the prehistory um i
talk about spirit possession ignored or
marginalized
so
basically you know
in this earliest period you know spirit
possession
in general has always been stigmatized
within both colonial and post-colonial
scholarship on religion it is seen as a
remnant of the historical and
civilizational precursors to the world
of historical religions people don't
talk about spirit mediums and spirit
possession being central to uh
you know um the
the the vision of the ethic of the
ethical good life and the practices and
of how to gain transcendence
if you're you know a christian or a
muslim or a buddhist or you know judaism
or whatnot it's you know in that sense
spirit position possession has always
been located as a kind of relic or
survival
of a pre-world historical religious
imaginary and you can see that
in many common semantic associations of
spirit possession uh shamanism magic
divination superstition animism spirit
cults these are all terms that are
circulate around it or sometimes can
uh serve as a replacements i mean and
they all sort of point to
a pre-world historic religion religious
imaginary and oftentimes spirit
possession i think is seen as a kind of
descendant or stepchild of shamanism um
and but this has created a kind of
foundational conceptual dilemma spirit
possession is always constituted as
radically other two and outside the
world historical religions and this
historical and civilizational framing
creates
this enduring dilemma about how to
understand the relationship between
spirit positions possession and world
historical religions spirit possession
tends to always look like something
illicit which doesn't belong in a world
religion but has been surreptitiously
smuggled into it
and for scholars of southeast asian
buddhism
they've tended to conceptualize this
relationship
and this belonging and the smuggling
through the lens of this idea of
syncretism which i will talk about along
the way
um
so
you know you can see in this earliest
period of scholarship
its spirit possession has been ignored
and marginalized in the study of
southeast asian buddhism because
scholars are working on
you know documenting studying
things that were seen as more canonical
widespread and mainstream um and spirit
mediums and possession didn't seem to
have any relation to these right so
making sense of monks and lady and and
their relations to each other making
sense of monasteries and temple life
what is the sangha what is monastic life
what's the pronunciatory path different
kinds of rituals and actions like
meditation and merit making and ritual
cycles
uh
you know how to understand cosmology and
karma and rebirth how to understand
nirvana and practical ethics and what
the good life is you know for most
scholars
uh
especially you know in the colonial
post-colonial era spirit possession and
spirit meetings have seemed irrelevant
to sort of really making sense of all of
that
so you can basically see that sort of
budologists and religious studies
scholars who work with
primarily sort of canonical literary
sources
um in southeast asia of theravada
buddhism
you know
those sources
are silent for the most part about
spirit possession and spirit mediums or
they have negative representations of
them in terms of malevolence and
inauspiciousness and beastly arts and
things that need to be exercised
and there's also no real obvious
institutional presence or significance
of spirit possession in the region which
is different than tibetan buddhism which
has state oracles right you have highly
accomplished monastics
who
are possessed by uh guardian deities and
then
um you know the dalai lama and other
figures consult with these possessed
beings right so
there's nothing like state oracles in
the tibetan or in the in the southeast
asian buddhist tradition um
you know it's been marginalized by
historians and anthropologists there
aren't many historical
references to spirit possession and
archival sources they didn't you know
their voices weren't recorded they
didn't produce records uh that were you
know preserved um
anthropologists have been
the ones who have you know
recognized and focused on spirit
possession the most and it makes
frequent appearances in anthropological
studies but usually it's relatively
brief because they themselves
anthropologists are focusing on those
same kind of more
mainstream conventional sorts of uh
topics um and this is even true in later
generations of scholarship after 1965
there's an explosion of ethnographies
written by anthropologists about
buddhism in southeast asia and um
usually discussions of spirit
possessions sort of show up in a you
know a paragraph or two or some
footnotes or whatnot
so
um the first kind of exceptions of this
came with anthropologists and
anthropologists have been the majority
of the scholars
looking at spirit possession
uh in southeast asia so
there was a certain you know there was
an exception to the rule in terms of
even anthropologists uh and i see this
as this first generation of scholarship
and i see it in this era from 1965 to
1985 and my trope is
you know they
think of spirit possession as this
domesticated niche within buddhist
southeast asia
so
there's basically three uh scholars
melford spiro who worked uh looked at
possession and the nat cults in burma um
and stanley tambaya who worked on
uh
studied possession in the context of
spirit cults in northeast thailand and
uh a thomas kirsch who worked on uh
[Music]
spirit possession and the sort of the
buddhist order in
also in northeast thailand um and
there's not a lot of other scholars who
really sort of focus in
with much more you know with much more
depth in terms of spirit possession uh
during this period but um
but these are sort of primary sources
that people keep going back to for
reference points
in later generations um
so
basically you have them they've been
working in myanmar and thailand these
seminal pieces their scholarship didn't
aren't really centered in laos although
you can think about northeast thailand
as sort of a an ethnic lao uh sort of
borderland between
siam or thailand and laos um but no
nobody's really from cambodia
um
and
you know these scholars focused on
certain empirical sorts of things they
spent a lot of time elaborating the ties
of spirit possession to pre-buddhist
religiosity and animism and or the
spirit cults um they saw spirit
possession as strongly emblematic of
local and of the local folk religiosity
found in rural peasant
excuse me society and culture
they spent a decent amount of time
thinking about trance and how that
related to other kinds of
ritual experiences but also
looking at the ritual process that
spirit mediums took part in and how it
played out and the way it was part of uh
ritual healing um
uh spiro actually said his book was
called burmese supernaturalism he said
he could have entitled it instead
burmese medicine uh that was that's how
closely he saw these kinds of uh topics
um they all tend to look at spirit
possession and spirit mediums as
providing this narrow set of mundane
worldly benefits that were really not
they didn't see it provided by orthodox
buddhist actors or activities right so
it's not just that you don't turn to a
spirit medium for help in terms of
gaining uh
liberation from samsara or in terms of a
better rebirth or even in terms of some
of like the kind of benefits you can get
from merit making instead it's you know
narrower kinds of things in terms of
local concerns right violating you know
norms about belonging in kinship groups
or in like village communities or sexual
ethoses and and rules and whatnot so um
or healing of particular kinds of
illnesses that have been brought about
by
uh maybe uh affliction by malevolent
beings and whatnot so um and the other
thing they all talk about is how these
spirit possession provides a sort of uh
a stage in which there's a kind of
sanctioned bachnalion excess and
pleasure and that this has a certain you
know it's like a it's like a legitimate
kind of uh violation of conventional
buddhist norms in terms of drinking
and uh
revelry and all this other stuff um um
and they all
in various degrees map out how spirit
mediums
uh are this you know constitution are
one end of a poll of a kind of
segregated structural opposition between
from spirit mediums to buddhist monks
and though they look at it in terms of
like the kinds of rituals they perform
engage in the the behavioral ethos
um
even their presence on a ritual stage
they will talk about how you know uh
buddhist monks exit when you know then
later you know spirit mediums will enter
even if it's a kind of conjoint ritual
in some sense they're almost spatially
and temporarily segregated in many ways
and there's a reticence in their kind of
engagement um you know analytically
these scholars are spending a lot of
time trying to make sense of the
character and dynamics of syncretism
which you know is related and and how
these different pieces sort of fit
together
how spirit
mediums and spirit possession sort of
sits inside of the world
structured and dominated by buddhist
values and and
principles um they're also all to some
degree working with this question of the
great tradition and the little tradition
and how
buddhism as a world historical religion
has been localized uh in in the region
but also within agricultural communities
they're all sort of trying to map the
total religious field of these rural
peasant villages where they did their
research um
uh tambaya has this sort of you know a
famous uh map of a sort of a four-part
map of these different religious sort of
virtuosos monks and mediums and the uh
the masters of vital essences and
exorcists and the different kinds of
rituals and and uh performative and even
material cultures that sort of uh spread
out of that
kirsch tends to talk about
buddhist and brahmanical
and animistic sort of uh divisions in
the religious field and and how they are
related to each other right um
and um they're all sort of you know to
the degree they focus on spirit mediums
and spirit possession it's in order to
illuminate this larger puzzle of how
syncretism works how localization works
how they really religious field works
um
so their discussions of spirit
possession spirit mediums are sort of um
are our our roots into that um
and they all approach these from
different kinds of perspectives
um in the anthropological tradition um
spiro has a kind of functionalist and
he's a psychological anthropologist and
formed by
freyan uh kinds of thinking tambaya is
is sort of more of a british social uh
anthropologist and formed by
structuralist kinds of models kirsch
is an american trained
who's been formed by parsons and his
vision of sort of sociological sort of
dynamics and structure
um
and
the way they conceptualize spirit
position in southeast asian buddhism
they tend to talk about it in terms of
like i said syncretism
curse uses this language of inclusive
syncretism i've sort of tended to add
hegemonic on to that so
spirit possession is seen as
hegemonically dominated by buddhism it's
domesticated and constrained
in its practices and actions and scope
by buddhist actors and institutions and
beliefs and practices um
there's even a sense especially from
curse that historically spirit
possession has been if it is this
remnant of a pre-buddhist kind of world
view it's been reconfigured over time
and even fragmented in certain ways so
that it is ultimately subordinate to
buddhist values and goals and frames of
references and spirit possession
therefore is seen as essentially kind of
peripheral to the normative mainstream
orthodox buddhist order and it and it
provides this specialized niche
of uh unique but relatively marginal
services activities experience and
functions for
rural village southeast asians um when
looked at from the
frame of what a buddhist good life is
and what uh moral practices and ritual
practices one should engage in
and i just want to emphasize here this
these these terms have like dominated
constrained subordinated peripheral
marginal because you know not to sort of
ruin the plot line or the rest of the
talk but
you could see
uh the later generations in different
ways essentially
challenging these kinds of this language
uh
qualifying it
maybe pushing back even more in terms of
dismantling it or disagreeing with it
displacing it or even
you know inverting these kinds of claims
um
as they encounter
um
spirit possession in buddhist southeast
asia and you know the thing to keep in
mind is that
um
you know
the later generations are encountering
uh
a different you know spirit possession
itself and spirit mediums are changing
right
in subsequent decades so the scholars
are encountering uh
you know uh
transformed visions of spirit possession
and spirit mediumship and also um
they're encountering uh
you know it's a totally transformed kind
of buddhist world and broader social
world as well
so
the second generation i see is this
20-year period from 1985 to 2005
and this is when basically you're
thinking about the trope is spirit
possession
as religious innovation within buddhist
south east asia
so
you know myanmar as a site of study a
spirit possession in buddhist southeast
asia has fades in this era because
people you know anthropologists who
primary people studying
uh this phenomenon
obviously for political reasons i found
it difficult to get into the country um
and the one exception is benedict brecht
de la perriere who you know wrote a book
and many articles on the cult of the 37
knots following in spiro's uh footprints
um but other than that it
works sort of dwindles um
there's some historical work so the most
the scholarship in this period is
comes out of thailand frankly um
it's
the topic still isn't on the horizons
for people working in laos or cambodia
the same way um
and this these studies are strongly
shaped by this intensifying post-world
war ii transformation of thailand it
began before this period
right in the 60s and then essentially
the 70s um you know you have extensive
rural urban migration exploding
urbanization a rapid growth in education
especially higher education
intensification of capitalist
development the growth of a professional
middle class
deepening democratization and expansion
of civil society burgeoning mass media
intensifying nationalism and even the
revival of the monarchy and all of these
i won't go into the details but they
also fit into you know these are the
forces that are transforming spirit
possession and spirit mediumship on the
ground um so
in terms of new foci that come up all of
a sudden you see all these studies a lot
of these studies talk about the just you
know spirit mediums in cities the
discovery of spirit mediums in cities
like chiang mai and bangkok and khan
khan in particular
and um you know people didn't talk about
prior generations didn't talk about
spirit mediums in cities um this new
generation also
really digs into you know their their
the other thing about their scholarship
is unlike uh spiro tembay and kirsch
they have a lot you know their their
publications are focused sort of
exclusively on spirit mediums and going
into detail about mediums and possession
um a lot of articles no books so they go
into you know unpacking the biographies
of individual spirit mediums and how
individuals become spirit mediums in
much fuller kind of uh
details uh taking apart geographies
taking about oral accounts of their of
how individuals became spirit mediums um
there's also a lot of documentation
about how spirit mediums sit at the
center of and embedded within
master student
lineages of instruction
of various sorts with actual individuals
and with mythic figures and this was not
really discussed much in the prior
generations um there's a lot of work on
how spirit mediums sit at the center of
they have an entourage of followers a
network of patrons
circles of clients they have their own
students as well and so sort of uh
describing and mapping that is important
for making sense of what spirit
possession is um and sometimes you know
these groups
even become more like religious
movements or cults of an even kind of
broader
scale
there's a lot of discussion about how
you know the way in which these sort of
spirit mediums found in cities are
are following vocational careers you
know
in prior you know prior studies of
spirit mediumship in rural areas would
often talk about how individuals become
you know who spirit mediums would become
possessed occasionally during certain
kinds of ceremonies or in certain kinds
of
crises certain kinds of annual cycles
but the spirit mediums in these cities
are basically like they're hanging up a
shingle
and they are sort of available to help
people you know day in you know uh like
every week and sometimes you know
multiple days during the week so um they
really are sort of like
vocational careers they are they are you
know often
uh
religious careers of virtuoso in which
you know that's actually a primary means
by which they're supporting themselves
in terms of livelihood there's also
discussion about how
there's growing numbers every everyone's
talking about how there's growing
numbers of them across
the country and within regions and the
diversifying demographics of them so
that there's not just you know there
used to be the notion that
spirit mediums were mostly women and or
transgendered uh
uh people but you know increasingly
there's a recognition that you know uh
there's there's cisgendered males and
other folks doing this um so that's part
of the sort of the
making sense of who spirit mediums are
and what spirit possession is um
and there's also this overwhelming sense
that spirit mediums
uh
and spirit possession itself is newly
assertive as a public presence and has a
kind of prominence in
in uh local settings and in the country
both in terms of in person the kind of
rituals they're
performing in public but also in terms
of the mass media mass media sort of
popular mass media thai language mass
media picks them up
looks at them examines them
they write their own sort of accounts of
their experiences and and have those
sort of placed inside of mass media um
there's a lot you know
uh the vision
the
image of spirit mediums also focuses on
how they forge social financial and
ritual relations sometimes contentious
sometimes idiosyncratic with buddhist
monks typically with them as junior
partners so there's this sense of
there's a lot more documentation about
how spirit mediums have these sort of um
somewhat tense
and complicated relationships with
particular monks in in this or that
location or temple
and engaged in joint kinds of uh
religious projects or ritual activity
and that wasn't really emphasized or
even
uh
present in in the prior generation
scholarship and then there's just this
general sense that
spirit mediums are these
innovative religious entrepreneurs
there's there's whole you know there's a
lot of documentation about these new
kinds of gods that are possessing them
that are drawn from chinese pantheons or
hindu pantheons indian pantheons
uh
pantheons of royal figures um
there's a there's a lot of focus on
they're doing new kinds of rituals and
techniques
um
some drawn from buddhist actors some
drawn from astrologers
uh whatnot um
they use they talk a lot about merit bun
and baramis or perfected virtue and
other kinds of buddhist terminologies
make sense of their experience of
possession and the power of the
possessing deities these deities are
seen as as repositories of
me this is not the way people talked
about the kinds of spirits that
possessed you know figures in the prior
generations
studies um
and uh
there's a lot of discussion about how
these sorts of spirit mediums
have display a behavior that mimics
normative
ethos they're like
vegetarians and they sometimes you know
are very displayed very prominently
they're celibate uh that they
engaged in they engage in meditation
that they sponsor uh merit making
activities and all this other uh sorts
of elements that make them look more
proper and normative and pious and um
and these
these spirit mediums are also shown as
sort of
um you know they're drawing on buddhist
mainstream buddhist material and visual
cultures they make amulets of the gods
uh that possess them
they make statues of the gods or they
and what not so they're sort of much
more embedded in
uh the kind of visual material
uh performative culture of of southeast
asian buddhism or thai buddhism um
very quickly the analytic themes is they
you know there's this sense that
uh
analyses of how these spirit mediums are
remaking village religiosity in the city
either rural migrants uh who have
brought it with them or mobile urbanites
who have encountered it in their travels
around the country um
there's an analyses of how you basically
have an ethnic majority tie sort of
appropriating and reworking elements
from ethnic minority religions like
chinese popular religion or indian
popular religion in terms of their
religious self-identities and how
they're appropriating and reworking
royalists sacrality um even as their
non-royals in the sense that uh they're
possessed by these sort of
past royal uh
past kings and monarchs and royal
figures
um
and you know there's there's always this
sense that these kinds of spirit mediums
this kind of possession is speaking to
uh you know it's a newly it's a newly
constituted kind of religious identity
and vocational career and that it's
designed to satisfy new clienteles and
followers
uh migrants proletariats
uh in the city professionalized middle
classes even educated globalized elites
um
and so there's this sense of spirit
mediums as these religious entrepreneurs
who are trafficking and providing a kind
of stigmatize often stigmatized form of
worldly prosperity religion people talk
about them as leaders of prosperity
cults peter jackson had a you know put
spirit mediums along with other kinds of
figures who led prosperity cults in the
1980s and 90s uh
and beyond and he's he's written about
that um
and basically you know con when you try
to when these second generation tries to
conceptualize spirit possession in
relation to southeast asian buddhism
they talk about syncretism still
although there's uh more tensions and
anxiety about it so i would see it as
sort of thinking about fractious
inclusive syncretism it doesn't seem to
fit as neatly as it used to
and um
some of them
jettison the idea of syncretism and want
to talk about other things like
hybridity
scholarship focuses on that so
but you know the way spirit position is
possession is now seen as situated
inside of southeast asian buddhism is
that you know it's sort of incorporating
and using normative buddhist beliefs and
practices to justify their existence a
kind of buddhistization of possession
and therefore there's more discussion
about idiosyncratic or unorthodox and
even heterodox ways that spirit mediums
act with regards to buddhist beliefs and
practices uh marjorie muck has this
famous essay where you know she she
documents
uh
three monks who are essentially students
of a spirit medium and act you know and
and very you know clearly sort of uh
defer in terms of authority to the
spirit media um
um and there's more discussion about how
there's this tension and conflict
between spirit mediums and buddhist
monks as well as the sangha and the
mainstream buddhism and spirit mediums
are seen as sort of speaking back and
criticizing the sangha and monks and
sometimes mainstream buddhists um so in
all these ways
you know
uh
these this this second generation of of
work on spirit possession in buddhist
southeast asia
has emphasized the way it strains the
image of this kind of uncontested
hegemonic inclusivism inclusive
syncretism um and that it strains the
image that they're just a specialized
niche providing
unique but relatively marginal services
because they're they are you know
providing a wider set of services that
are more conventional and mainstream and
that clearly
uh
this idea of a segregated structural
opposition between spirit mediums and
monks
is uh is seen as questionable
or sort of faltering
so then we come to the third generation
of scholarship which is where i see this
the
contributions of this book uh being
placed
and my trope i'm not totally happy with
it i'm interested that's what we're
hearing now that's what we're hearing
is multiple spirit possessions as
alternative pieties within buddhist
southeast asia um
so that's basically where
i would place you know the the works in
this volume um they i think
foreground
everybody bear with us as we try to
figure out what happened to eric's uh
connection
i'll send him a brief email just one
second
um
and um
there's also the sense that
they're engaged with
more than just monks usually the
discussion was always about spirit
mediums and monks in relation to each
other but they're also seen you know
interacting with state brokers and civil
society cheering
heritage
um
now also
are you know even more deeply engaged
with like culture industries except
print and digital mass media and social
media they use social media to to
expand and preserve their entourages and
to reach out to clienteles
you know
families and rituals they take part in
um
and that actually sometimes there's even
another element that's new is
their social organization becomes even
more complex one of the articles and
talks about how there was a temporarily
a kind of effort to create an
association
in
chiang mai uh with formal kinds of you
know positions and authority and
relations that it's
apart for various reasons that you can
read the article about um and there's
even cases of
another thing that scholars have noticed
there's cases of these sort of the role
of spirit mediums and buddhist monks
actually collapsing into each other with
more you know documentation of
individuals who ordain temporarily as
most but who are and have been spirit
mediums in the past and the complicated
way they negotiate that kind of
uh wearing both of those hats even if
only a temporarily um
and a final element that you see in a
lot of
is
that the
you know there's a sense that
france and possession and position like
behavior actually extend beyond just
self-identified spirit mediums but that
you find other actors including monks
whether it's you know
visions or dreams or translate behavior
you know they're doing things that echo
uh
what sort of looks like possession that
has possession like qualities then they
valorize it they give it different terms
and languages um but there's a kind of
uh
uh similarity and so you know basically
um
you know analytically the other thing
that this new scholarship looks at that
you find in this book is that
scholars are situating spirit mediums
and spirit possessions in relation to
vernacular buddhist beliefs and
practices on the ground rather than
the official literary buddhism
that are conveying canonical
establishment or elite voices so there's
sort of uh more ground and room for
possession
[Music]
is that um
are
uh
in the past it was only thinking about
them in relation to like monks and the
sangha and or the state but increasingly
there's a lot of attention paid to the
way they relate to the market in terms
of commercialism and commodification
the way they relate to civil society in
terms of culture industries
media
academics academic scholarships
associations
cultural heritage and tourism so the
broadening of the sense of what how
spirit positions and spirit mediums
side of the larger
social uh terrain beyond just
um
so
the final point i'm going to make
essentially is
when it comes to conceptualizing spirit
possession and southeast asian buddhism
for the third generation um people don't
talk about synthetism but there's a lot
of anxiety about it and how to
characterize it um you know i've added
advertisers when i read people's
scholarships sometimes they seem to be
talking about like siloed forms of
syncretism or fissured forms of
synthetism
or competitive forms of syncretism
others have started to try to reach for
language like polytrophy or creolization
as they continue to struggle to make
sense
of spirit possession
of
a buddhist-dominated kind of religious
world
and um
so
um
sexually there's been this growing sense
that like the conventional way of
dividing us the religious world that's
medically mixed together
is too limited right you can't just talk
about buddhism and brahmanism and
animalism there's other elements whether
it's hinduism or royal stuff or
curiosity
a number of other kinds of ways of
thinking about
influences and religious traditions that
are sort of make up the total mix and
therefore that also opens up ways in
which where they locate and the first
series of scholars only located their
possession inside of sort of animism
which was the most subordinated element
but now you can see how spirit mediums
and spirit position can set inside of a
lot of other kinds of
nations of religious you know tradition
and practice if you expand the horizons
of
what of what this composite
southeast asian buddhist world looks
like historically
so
you know
the final case then i would make is that
all of this is to say that amongst these
most current scholars of spirit
possession that you will find in this
book
um
you know
they all for them it's all much more
difficult to claim that spirit
possession and spirit mediums are so
easily or effectively
dominated constrained
subordinated peripheralized or marginal
overarching buddhist social order
because they have been encountering more
and more spirit mediums who themselves
are pushing back against that and
claiming that they do fit inside they
belong
inside that world as good proper uh
buddhists and we see
so
a lot of the spirit mediums that are
encountered and then the scholars
themselves studying that are you know
uh end up taking positions quite
different
first generation of scholars
the parameters of houses
spirit
so that's i'll end it
sorry
great thank you eric and thank you for
um responding to the technical
difficulty in continuing with the end of
the talk i really appreciate that um
so what we'll do now is we'll open up to
q a for a little bit um can i ask
everyone when you say your q a just make
sure that eric was able to hear the
answer clearly the question clearly be
before once you've completed just to
make sure that we have a clear line of
communication going here
um
are there any uh
hands who would like to go first
with a question
i'm back
oh you're back
okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna kill the phone i'm getting
getting a rebound from it okay eric so
thomas
and then janet hoskins after that go
ahead
eric can you hear me yep i can hear you
good
great thank you uh thanks for the talk
uh
um
super helpful actually to think about
the the kind of this the scope of of the
study i have
um
two questions uh
one is
thinking about the second generation of
scholarship
um as you described it uh all sorts of
language of innovation and new and
transformation and new and new and new
and um
i'm wondering if
to what degree there's something really
new happening and to what degree do we
actually just see people paying
attention to what's been going on for a
long time and the first generation of or
the you know the pre-1965 and the first
generation of scholars
just ignored it or didn't realize it was
going on or what how what have you the
second the second question
um and it really points to it's it's
really about the third generation of of
uh were the the contemporary
spirit mediums
in in
mainland southeast asia
nathan kaplan's book on monastic
education in korea
points to really interesting ways in
which
korean
buddhists
in their institutional structures are
clearly reading
um european
and american scholarship and histories
of
of
buddhist studies
and it informs
buddhist education in korea in in very
interesting ways um
and and you know so there's this
feedback loop and i'm wondering to what
degree do we see um
uh spirit mediums in contemporary
thailand uh for example um
how much are they aware of the
scholarship that you've just been
talking about uh are do they know about
it or is it or is it something that's um
you know not not visible to them thanks
very much okay great questions so the
first one i think it is you know part of
the distinctive approach
part of the distinctiveness between the
first and the second generation is
they're different generations of
anthropologists so they're bringing
different assumptions and and and
techniques you see a lot more attention
to like cultural politics and uh
uh historical dynamics and historical
ethnography right in the second
generation that wasn't there in the
first and there is also this sense of um
uh you know
a lot of these second generation
anthropologists
have also they've they've migrated you
know from studying rural peasants to
society to other kinds of social domains
so
um
part of the newness
is
that they're looking anew right there's
no i i have not been able to find any
you know
sustained ethnographic studies of
religion in chiang mai or bangkok right
that really sort of uh attend in much
from that are actually set in that
earlier generation from 65 to 85 there
aren't that many
right anthropologists doing work in
urban areas
texture i mean there's a bit here and
there and you can see you can see little
suggestive echoes of of what the second
generation discovers so i am quite
certain that it was there to a certain
degree previously right and one way i do
know that is
um there were some japanese skull
anthropologists who did their
traditionally amazingly
like empirically detailed studies
of religion in bangkok and um i finally
got their work translated into english
and i could tell from the visuals and
they were doing work you know the work i
have is from the 70s and they're clearly
discussing um
religious and social forms organized
around possession
that are echoes of what the scholars are
finding in that in from like the 80s on
um they don't look exactly the same
they're precursors that have their own
kind of like dynamics they seem to be
coming out of urban chinese popular
religiousity in bangkok as much so
there's so that suggests that you know
in that case it wasn't it wasn't you
know
it wasn't because these the ideas were
transmitted from like the rural society
and reworked it's coming from an alter a
different kind of in a talk and
indigenous source that that the prior
generations of scholar anthropologists
just tended not to see because they
weren't doing work in urban areas so
there's something definitely there
but the you know the documentary
evidence is is pretty fragmented and not
very extensive but i assume what you're
suggesting is true and similarly
we actually sort of get a decreasing
sense of these questions in terms of
rural society in the 80s and the 90s
among western scholar anthropologists
because they're not doing the same kinds
of intense studies there so we can't
even track how it's changing in the
rural areas you do in the third
generation you have more scholars like
benjamin bauman and others looking at
possession in rural areas in the wake of
all these transformations and
reimaginings and and seeing things
colliding in ways right um
and in terms of that kind of weather
mediums
so
most of the
of the spirit mediums i've ever
encountered in my work from the 90s on
in bangkok that's where i did my
research
they're not particularly
um
fluent in english
so the degree that they get access to
academic models it's because they're
reading
thai language popular press
which often will
draw on
thai anthropologists
who are studying religion and
contemporary society and maybe even
possession and those thai scholars
have been informed by
those seminal works by the first
generation of of of foreign scholars
right or even earlier ones like thai
scholars like rajamoun and what not like
that so
so they're getting it maybe two or three
degrees of distance and reserve and
mediation right and they're encountering
it because they're encountering the mass
media there's much more
spectacularization
and drama right around these kinds of
visions of what it means to be a spirit
medium there's not this sort of more
um sort of reserved scholarly kind of
annotation and detail and notation so i
think some of it is seeping through i
mean they're clearly reading you know
spirit mediums i've always encountered i
mean they're just you know they're
deeply reading like popular mass media
and all this other stuff and um in fact
now you know
i didn't talk about the thai language
scholarship on spirit mediums but you
know i've come across recent
dissertations by thai monks who have
studied spirit mediums right so there's
a complex kind of conversation going on
between academics and spirit mediums as
well um being mediated through language
right and class and all this other stuff
and there's a lot of there's a lot of
thai you know master's students who've
gone out and done studies of
of ceremonial cycles that involve spirit
mediums and possession
all over the country right as parts of
kind of local ethnic or territorial
identity and social worlds and that's
out there and it's all like you know
it's all available for download digital
download now right and you know so
it'd be hard to track but i wouldn't be
surprised if this stuff doesn't start
reverberating to the greater degree that
they become
you know uh
literate in accessing and using and
knowing about this kind of uh
uh scholastic work about popular
religion and spirit possession and
mediumship that's floating around out
there so thanks for the questions yeah
janet we have a question from you and
then after janet from karen myers
okay thank you um i'd actually like to
ask the same question that you asked me
during discussion to eric
you know why
why do you think that the vietnamese
studies of spirit possession have been
siloed
after i provided one approximate answer
another one sort of occurred to me but
i'd rather hear directly from you what
you think yeah well i'll offer up my
thoughts and then i'd be interested to
hear what you think too i mean in
general i have to be honest the study of
religion
in
myanmar
thailand laos and cambodia
has tended
to not pay attention to the vietnamese
world i mean across the board
you know i think part of it is is
it's not seen as part of this sort of
theravada majority world or parts of
vietnam that sort of have that presence
so it just hasn't been part of the the
training of scholars um
it's more complicated because clearly
there's a kind of cynic world right a
cynic kind of logic of organizing
religion and popular religion that's
going on there
and so it's a little more challenging
for scholars of mainland southeast asian
terrible buddhist majority countries who
have not been exposed to that kind of
scholarship and ideas in literature but
it is a problem and it's kind of ironic
because you know it is it is very common
in the history at least of thai you know
buddhism to point to these important
figures who were introduced innovation
and often it's these it's it's it's the
chi it's the sino ties who have been
sort of negotiating different religious
worlds and they have spun out new ideas
inside of thai buddhism and thai
religiosity in general so the same logic
would apply to spirit possession
because actually there's lots of thai
buddhists even if they're not sino-thai
who have now you know they're exposed to
the chinese pantheon and logics and
they're claiming that you know they're
being possessed by ta uh by chinese gods
of various sorts and all of this even if
they're not sinutai in terms of their
own ethnic origins right in history and
so
it would make sense for
um
for thai scholars or for scholars of
spear possession in thailand and in you
know other the other countries of
mainland southeast asia to really pay
attention more not only to vietnam but
to
the sonitic kind of world of reliability
and how it has influenced
historically in the past and in the
present what's going on um in where
they're working um and it's actually
kind of you know it's
it's kind of i'll be honest like i have
i have diligently collected as much of
the scholarship on vietnamese spirit
possession and mediums as i can find
but i haven't had the time to dig
through it because there's in the detail
i'd like to but it's embarrassing
because you know between 2005 and now
there's been an explosion of monographs
and edited volumes that actually just
dwarfs what's going on in the mainland
theravada part of of southeast asia um
that's that's been studying this you
know for decades longer and yet as a
publishing kind of project it has not
produced you know edited volumes and
monographs in the same way there are
very few monographs
you know focused
in a narrow sense on spirit possession
and spirit mediumship in
in the
theravada majority part of mainland
southeast asia right um
so i think it's mostly about training
and exposure and maybe
you know prop language right you know
like you know to a certain degree you it
it's the usual problem like you'd have
to study vietnamese and you'd really you
know it would be good to know chinese as
well to really be able to make sense of
this stuff and it's
it's just you know it's it's it's
difficult because of training and
constraints
were there other thoughts you had that
um i actually had a different response
which was more about the influence of
vietnamese language scholars
partly because it was
it was very difficult to study religion
at one point in vietnam and the fact
that it has become more possible for
vietnamese scholars and for foreign
scholars is something we owe in part
to um a particular folklore institute
run by no dicting that has been very
influential
and uh but i think what's also true is
that when you talk to people from other
parts of southeast asia they say well
the vietnamese aren't really as buddhist
as we are
which may be a kind of local
ethnocentrism they're not theravada
buddhist
and
and certainly buddhism doesn't have the
place in vietnam that it has in thailand
the the trip place of tremendous power
and sort of central
um
religious influence because buddhism is
competing against many other
uh forms of religiosity and um
one thing that that this folklore
institute did is they they labeled
spirit possession as as a dao
and that in itself makes it in a sense
independent from buddhism
although there are a lot of these
collaborations that you're talking about
and certainly there are monks who
collaborate with spirit mediums and so
forth but um
that has sort of reconfigured the
religious field in interesting ways yeah
no i think that's all true and i don't
think i don't think heritage and
folklore studies sort of has played the
same sort of thing in the theravada
mainland world and um
um
and there is something about the
complicated sectarianism
right even in terms of buddhism but
beyond that of the religious world of
vietnam that is
confusing and challenging to scholars
trained to think about you know
religious worlds that are clearly
dominated by a kind of terra vadan
sectarian whatever it's local
vernacularization a terror a singular
theravadin kind of orthodoxy right um so
i think that's part of it too yeah
thanks
aaron you can go ahead thanks okay
thanks um thanks for that talk i really
appreciated the literature review um i
work more in tibetan buddhism
um but so i was curious as to how much
of the
um literature
you talked a little bit about
cross-cultural analysis between these
you know southeast asian countries but
how much of the
uh literature really engages i mean it's
a worldwide phenomena right spirit
possession
um and if you could cite any works that
really engage in that comparative uh
question in a robust way
well i have to say i've always been
surprised that
scholars working on spirit possession in
teravata buddhists southeast asia
um
have not tended to look outside the
region and the sectarian orders the way
i would have imagined again i have large
collections of scholarship on possession
in tibetan buddhism and even china and
india right and especially sri lanka i
got to say that's the most striking
thing
most scholars working on spear
possession in myanmar or thailand
cambodia they never think about the sri
lankan case which is just so obvious um
you know
john holt has seen this book and he was
kind of like where's where's sri lanka
in this project and i was like well they
envisioned it in a regional sense so
they didn't go there but there's another
reason for whatever reason
it's just that linguistic cultural zone
and training thing they just don't seem
to look there again
just like in vietnam there's a large
body of monographs and volumes and other
stuff about spirit possession in sri
lanka and yet
i don't find scholars thinking about it
i try to think about it um
but honestly it's you know i think i
don't know
so um and then going beyond that i mean
you know
spirit possession looks different like
in india it looks very different in
tibet right and then i you know i mean
like east asia is another world right
you could have an interesting
comparative volume about how spirit
possession is configured differently in
these regions and the sectarian
traditions and i hope
people try to sort of
you know
uh
open up those kinds of conversations and
projects because i think it would be
very fruitful and would
would energize the study to see the
kinds of i mean i've taken part in these
sort of these workshops on buddhism that
you know had been run in paris and you
know and that kind of cross-sectarian
cross-regionalism has been very um
instructive and informative for me
thinking about what i'm seeing on the
ground
you know uh
in the present but also what people have
talked about in terms of the past in
terms of mainland southeast asia and or
thailand so
um
if you contact me you know sort of
i'd have to stop and think about you
know the scholarship that actually does
try to to to make those sorts of
connections um honestly a lot of the
anthropologists have been only
intermittently engaged with there's a
whole body of
conceptual analytical theoretical work
about just spirit possession inside of
anthropology
and they've
they've been
you know
it hasn't had a very significant impact
for the most part it's interesting i
sometimes you know thai study scholars
have have drank the kool-aid of a kind
of exceptionalism a little too much and
it sort of made them
you know inoculated against doing that
but um
so i'm not sure why but
you know
so there's a lot of other right kinds of
theoretical works either coming out of
other regions
uh and i would say you know the the
introduction by peter and benedict does
try to engage with some of this stuff
think critically about how that absence
has influenced past scholarship and our
approaches they don't sort of rectify
the problem but they know i mean they
basically argue you know that there is a
southeast asian possession complex and i
agree and disagree with them in certain
ways about that but they're basically
like you know let's think about
regional possession in terms of like
different kinds of you know regionalized
kind of complexes that have a different
you know distinct kinds of historical
and social logics and they are you know
they suggest that
scholars working on buddhist southeast
asia start thinking like that um so
so there are efforts to sort of push
that way but it's not clear
how much it'll be taken up by future
schools
yeah thank you it seems because one of
the questions is how does it relate to
buddhism
and so we could look at other buddhist
cultures but also non-buddhist cultures
that have spirit possession to get a
sort of broader okay
but i do think this comes
actually your comment makes me say that
again
you know the so the earliest scholars
laid down these kinds of
foundational sort of frames and
assumptions and the fact that the you
know the earliest scott you know spiro
and
uh and tambaya and kirsch were working
with this sort of issue of great
traditions little traditions and you
know buddhism and localization and all
of that that has tended to then sort of
close out other kinds of optics and
horizons
and
made scholars a little content later
generations of scholars just sort of not
see analytic and theoretical
possibilities because they're like
that's the big issue how does spirit
possession fit inside of
buddhist
logics and actors in the buddhist
religious field but what about all these
other kinds of questions um they tend to
be just sort of
they weren't they're not on the horizon
and so scholars don't always sort of see
them they don't jump out at them
and i did and i did sort of frame it in
terms of
that particular line of argument
um
okay
this is really great i'm just karen i
wanted to thank you for that question
because it's inspired me to talk to some
of my colleagues across the different
area councils you know we're southeast
asian studies but my colleagues in east
asian studies and south asian studies
and other places too interested in these
kinds of questions and i was thinking
well
we have some initiatives to think of a
kind of trans-regional buddhist studies
but it also makes us maybe need to
rethink that too right um
there's certainly great reason to do
that but to think maybe uh transnational
spirit possession studies or something
would be a really interesting kind of
framework as well
um i said that challenge had a a
question but in fact he met he was
waving to one of us so i don't want to
force him to have a question but knowing
taki always has a good question to ask
so i'll give you the opportunity talk if
you want to take up the offer actually
uh i was waving at rick rick ruth
anyway um
the question i had was already answered
because when listening to all this i was
thinking about
spirit possession in southeast asia
and the other
place that a lot of studies have been
made is actually the philippines
and so i was well i was going to ask
eric whether you know instead of talking
about just buddhism
if he could talk about spirit possession
and the philippines is is an interesting
case right it's catholic and or or
non-capital
it is right for the for the broader you
know but again for i think
scholars working in mainland southeast
asia they're intimidated when you go to
the insular world it's not just you know
social cultural political logics you
know an organization can be different
but then you're encountering islam and
christianity right in a certain sense as
these world historical traditions
and there is a sense that monotheistic
traditions you know have treated spirit
possession slightly different than
non-monotheistic traditions have been
less accommodating often um at least you
know scholarship twins
to suggest that so it's not like things
couldn't be learned but i think
again they see it as a little like like
you know it would be i think it would be
an easier step up to to look at like
spirit possession in the chinese world
and in the vietnamese world right and in
the south asian world
um
uh to the degree that they're in this
sort of uh non-monotheistic dominated
kind of religious orders and it's it's
another step up then to take into
account what's going on with spirit
possession when you're
when you're in um uh a christian or an
islamic kind of world that actually has
often seems to have stronger
prohibitions to exclude it right i mean
you know
despite being you know early scholars
thinking that spirit possession is the
subordinated marginal sort of thing it
is you know it's recognized by buddhists
and it is it is accommodated right and
tolerated in certain ways um except for
some of the most
modernist high modernist kinds of
thai bird buddhists or myanmar buddhists
who denounce it thoroughly right um but
there's a kind of accepting and
accommodation of it which can sometimes
seem to be harder in certain kinds of um
christian and muslim kinds of
environments so
it would definitely be you know
especially if you want to work the
regional kind of character right
um if
if benedict and peter are talking about
a southeast asian
sort of possession complex they are
mostly thinking about it in terms of the
mainland right they haven't you know
expanded that horizon to
uh the insular world um which which
could which would introduce certain
kinds of complexities
i received a note from rick ruth who got
the spirit of the wave from talk and now
wishes to answer a question as well i'm
sorry yeah yeah just actually two things
really quick first of all i wanted to
wish uh eric white a happy birthday uh
you bum
i did remember it was your birthday and
thank him for doing this
for it and actually i was thinking a lot
maybe about uh
in some ways we've been talking about
blending what we've seen as asian
american studies with uh regional
studies a lot lately i noticed more and
more departments are
combining or considering them together
and this afternoon we've been talking
about uh in some ways the geographical
siloing i guess between
vietnam and thailand and the philippines
now what i found myself wondering is
uh in terms of diasporic studies
are there studies of spirit medium
even specifically uh tai consung turning
up
uh in the united states i mean in our
lifetime in this kind of half century
that you've described we've seen
you know taiwan uh appearing in more and
more states across the country
as part of of that uh manifestation of
of southeast asian religion in north
america or in europe are there kunsan
zhao in in the united states and are
there anthropologists studying them
so
interestingly
i'm not i'm not sure i know the
literature as as well as i could or
should but
if when i think off the top of my head
um
it's in terms of the diaspora in america
and it's interestingly
i have seen analyses of spirit
possession in in sort of southeast asian
diasporic america in the cambodian and
the laotian worlds because of the the
demographics of you know uh refugees and
migration right um i wouldn't be
surprised if it's not popping up in you
know burmese and thai worlds as well
um but i've seen a few pieces of
scholarship but not a lot um so it is it
is sort of
uh there is a touch of that but um i've
never seen anything about spirit
possession amongst ethnic ties outside
of
mainland outside of southeast asia or
the extended sort of world of on the
borderlands
for instance maybe this is somewhere
within a fourth generation can go with
it then or yeah i mean that's that's
yeah that's certainly
one you know one direction i mean
there's so many different directions i
talk about issues and directions in my
afterward and peter and benedict talk
about it as well in their book
um i think actually ironically you know
in in relation to what janet was talking
about uh or karen
there's actually a it's a sense of of
going more intensely into
the southeast asian world which is to
say
increasingly scholars are pushing back
on the idea of okay so there's this
common kind of theravada buddhist
soci you know religious logic across all
of mainland southeast asia right but if
you you know they're like if you look at
the pantheons the pantheons don't look
the same the pantheons of possessing
spirits don't look the same across the
countries and even regions within the
country
and you can see the language and even
the kinds of the styles and kind the
modalities of spirit possession um that
are valorized and worth
you know uh cultivating they don't look
the same across these different worlds
so there's actually is increasingly a
sense that we have to pay more attention
to actually the historical and social
specificity of what you know um these
religious worlds and fields look like
you know
underneath the umbrella of the nation
state which tends to sort of
artificially homogenize everything much
less the umbrella of terra vada which
can even more powerfully homogenize
everything and there's a sense that
actually you know you've got
very localized pantheons that are kind
of uh open-ended and generatively
playing and paul sorrentino's article
about vietnamese spirit possession in
the mona in the edited volume goes into
great detail about
sort of the the the
creative um
ambiguities and slippages within the
vietnamese pantheon that has allowed you
know spirit possession to take on these
different shapes over from the colonial
era to the modern era and
and actually
jostling with visions of what the
pantheon is and who's in and out and the
logics of interacting with them but the
same thing i think applies
to local
theravada buddhist worlds of possession
and mediumship across the rest of
mainland southeast asia and so
um
[Music]
so that's you know
so that's a different kind that's a
totally different angle instead of sort
of going out it's even going deeper to
really sort of pay attention to local
history and society
and culture and politics and how it has
shaped things so that it's not all like
all spirit mediumship looks the same
from mandalay to to to phnom penh to to
you know luang prabang right um
well this brings us to 130 so i think
i'm gonna bring the the formal part of
our discussion to close and i'll stop
the recording but please join me in
a round of applause for eric's talk and
you're welcome to linger a little bit
for informal chit chat for a few moments